[Música]
si le da un paso más en la consagración
de su democracia y deja atrás el
recordado estallido social será tal vez
el mejor ejemplo de que en la dificultad
existe la oportunidad o al menos durante
esos días de manifestaciones y en medio
de la crisis institucional surgió esa
oportunidad para este país suramericano
eso sí a un alto costo porque una
treintena de chilenos fallecieron
durante esas manifestaciones y miles
resultaron heridos sin embargo este país
ya logró hacer consensos y cerró ese
capítulo lo dejó atrás y abrió otro al
ser entregada a la propuesta de la nueva
constitución la ceremonia tuvo lugar en
el antiguo edificio del congreso
nacional en el centro de santiago allí
el órgano constituyente entregó uno de
los ejemplares al presidente gabriel
boric estas fueron sus palabras sobre
este tema veamos
esta constitución
este proyecto de constitución y el
plebiscito que se desarrollará el 4 de
septiembre
no es ni debe ser un juicio del gobierno
es
el debate sobre el futuro y el destino
de chile para las próximas cuatro o
cinco décadas por lo tanto
como presidente de la republica lo
invito
a todos y todos a que debatamos con esa
altura de mira
quienes elaboraron esta nueva carta
magna y qué novedades tiene pues fue
redactada por una convención que tiene
variedad de género está integrada por
154 ciudadanos la mayoría de ellos son
independientes progresistas y buscan
declarar a chile' un estado social de
derecho novedades sólo por mencionar
algunas son 388 artículos en donde se
consagran derechos sociales como la
salud pública y universal educación
gratuita mejores pensiones para los
ciudadanos acceso a la vivienda y al
agua derecho a la interrupción del
embarazo y busca el carácter
plurinacional del estado chileno también
la autonomía de los pueblos originarios
como por ejemplo los mapuches y la
eliminación del senado
dicha propuesta debe ser aprobada
entonces por los ciudadanos chilenos
esto será en un referéndum nacional de
participación obligatoria que está
previsto para el 4 de septiembre en el
que de ser aprobada esta constitución
dejaría entonces atrás la constitución
actual del país que fue elaborada
durante la dictadura de augusto pinochet
que era de corte digamos un poco más
liberal fomentaba la privatización de
los servicios y para muchos es la gran
culpable de las divisiones sociales del
chile actual además de tener
precisamente un enfoque que se aleja de
el chile de la actualidad es esto cierto
ya lo analizaremos con nuestros
invitados lo que sí es verdad es que la
propuesta genera todo tipo de divisiones
entre los chilenos comenzó con una
amplia popularidad hace algunos meses
cómo está entonces esa popularidad de
esta nueva carta magna ante los
ciudadanos cómo se mueven las balanzas
de cara a la votación de septiembre
ahora que comienza una campaña de
difusión sobre esta propuesta a lo largo
y ancho de este país que dicen los
diferentes sectores de la sociedad
chilena con qué tanto apoyo cuenta esta
carta magna como podrá cambiar el futuro
del país analizar entonces en unos
minutos aquí en el debate de france 24
para conversar sobre este tema saludamos
a lucía miranda ellas académica de la
universidad católica silva henríquez en
chile- y de flacso ella se conecta desde
la ciudad de santiago y también desde la
capital chilena se conecta patricio
gajardo él es politólogo historiador
también es máster en estudios
internacionales de la universidad de
chile y también cuenta con una
especialización en estudios políticos
latinoamericanos de la universidad de
brasilia es profesor asociado en
ciencias políticas y relaciones
internacionales en la universidad de
chile y san sebastián les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todos sus
preguntas y sus comentarios a través de
las redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram y en facebook en donde nos
encuentran como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta se las recuerdo es numeral el
debate efe 24 también en youtube pueden
seguir nuestra señal en streaming y
también los invito para que escuchen el
podcast de nuestro programa todo nuestro
contenido está disponible en app el
podcast en spotify bendice y esperamos
todos sus comentarios y que nos oigan a
través de estas nuevas plataformas que
hemos habilitado para ustedes pues le
debe la bienvenida entonces a lucia ya
patricio para dar inicio a este programa
me gusta llamar a la primera pregunta
siempre la nombró si el punto de partida
que es para sondear un poco opiniones de
los invitados y comienzo con lucia
preguntándole allí en la ciudad de
santiago sobre esta nueva protesta
propuesta de la constitución es un paso
significativo sobre todo para apaciguar
y cerrar ese capítulo de la protesta
social de las manifestaciones que hubo
en ese país suramericano y tal vez
contemplar la posibilidad de un futuro
en chile distinto a lo que están
viviendo en este momento como lo ve
usted
de esta manera
[Música]
hoy
y también en resabios que la mantenía de
hong en términos económicos por un
modelo como estuviera en denominaba que
dejó plasmada la constitución anterior
de forma
liberal y que dejó sin protección a una
parte importante de la ciudadanía y que
se hizo saber esa falta de cobertura
estatal especialmente durante una crisis
social y económica que siempre se
negaron a cambiar en el país por tanto
en muchas su artículo 1 esta nueva
constitución viene a responder a esta
necesidad de estas peticiones de chile
que cambio y que se encarna en un estado
social democrático de derecho
plurinacional que reconoce el medio
ambiente como un elemento esencial para
que la calidad de vida de la ciudadanía
sea óptima y que no está muy lejos de lo
que se denuncia en constituciones todo
lo que compara con constituciones del
país del como españa alemania
nueva zelanda es decir condición que
entra dentro de los estándares
internaciones
y patricio también le doy la bienvenida
al programa y como punto de partida que
significa entonces esta nueva
presentación de esta propuesta esta
nueva constitución es un paso
significativo como lo decía para cerrar
ese capítulo del del estallido social y
contemplar la posibilidad de un país
significativamente diferente a lo que
han vivido en los últimos años cuál es
su punto de vista hola santiago bueno yo
creo que sí es un paso significativo
pero eso nace con el acuerdo del 15 de
noviembre del año 2019 que el que
estableció efectivamente llevará
adelante un proceso constitucional ahora
quiero dejar claro que la constitución
de 1980 ha sido modificada en muchas
oportunidades y hay una gran
modificación que lleva a cabo el
presidente ricardo lagos socialista el
año 2005 por lo tanto no es que pasamos
de la constitución de 1980 en la
dictadura de pinochet a este nuevo
proyecto
en relación a si es una salida
institucional yo creo que de eso se
trataba de que fuera una salida
institucional
lamentablemente no creo que haya sido
así yo creo que en la apuesta que se
hace por los sectores que participaron
en esta constitución que como tú
señalaba muy bien santiago tuvo un
sistema paritario
con pueblos indígenas con escaños
reservados con movimientos sociales
etcétera entonces no podemos decir de
que no hubo de alguna forma un
alineamiento previo que llevó a que el
proyecto que se presenta al menos todo
lo que conocemos porque hoy día recién
se hicieron las últimas modificaciones
indican que
la propuesta constitucional no
necesariamente va a lograr un consenso
si el acuerdo que todos los chilenos
esperábamos en esta nueva constitución
no te olvides que el plebiscito de
entrada el apruebo es decir la necesidad
de una nueva constitución fue aprobada
por un 78% de la población
sin embargo todas las últimas encuestas
señalan
que el rechazo estaría obteniendo un
mejor resultado que la prueba siempre y
ya en forma bastante contundente vamos a
ver si en estos dos meses que quedan
para el 4 de septiembre se consolida esa
tendencia o no
están las cargas para esa votación pero
no sé si se genere el consenso que se
planteó la coalición en la necesidad de
este proyecto y de este proceso
constitucional patricio ya vamos a
analizar cómo están las cargas para esa
votación no se me adelante en la agenda
ya lo vamos a analizar quería
preguntarle usted menciona que fue la
salida institucional
si era la salida correcta adecuada para
lo que estaba viviendo chile en ese
momento a raíz del estallido social era
la salida a esa crisis una constituyente
para redactar una nueva carta magna o
había otro camino no yo creo que sí yo
creo que era esta la salida estoy de
acuerdo de que había que buscar una
salida institucional los niveles de
violencia fueron muy fuertes durante el
estallido y por lo tanto yo creo que se
buscó y había una necesidad y por algo
tuvo el respaldo
78% que es un respaldo altísimo porque
después se llevó a cabo incluso la
elección en la presidencial en la cual
gana gabriel boric y fíjate tú por
ejemplo que cas que era el líder de la
ultraderecha obtuvo un 44 por ciento los
votos y sin embargo es el constituyente
el porcentaje de representación de la
centroderecha de los sectores más
moderados de la centroderecha incluso
eran irrelevante entonces es una
constitución que está hecha a la medida
de esa multa izquierda entonces creo que
él no va necesariamente a resolver el
problema de consenso que ojalá era lo
que todos los chilenos
lucia también allí en la ciudad de
santiago en ese orden de ideas y con
este panorama que hemos comenzado a
armar y saliendo nos un poco de las
fronteras chilenas en este país
suramericano logra convertir un
descontento social por diferentes
motivos en un proceso democrático
precisamente para solidificar digamos
así las bases de la democracia chilena
cuál es la elección que le deja este
país a otros procesos similares o
escenarios parecidos en américa latina
que uno pueda decir si le puede servir
de ejemplo o puede ser
simplemente para mirarlo con lupa
totalmente el cine con ejemplo en la
escritura en que los grados de una
estrategia democrática
realizaría responder a un nivel de
conflicto social tener que tener bien
clara no confundamos es muy importante
que tengamos el sentido de la palabra
contento de encendido de la palabra una
amiga
esta constitución nueva fue elaborada y
se logró gracias al concepto hay que
tener en claro que cada uno de sus
artículos fue aprobado con el doctor
tiene la vocación de la convención o más
esto implica que a un nivel de
negociación y diálogo elevadísimo
difiere claramente de una estrategia y
una habilidad por la cual fue aprobada
una constitución en dictaduras como la
constitución de
1980 la búsqueda del consenso es
positiva para la democracia una
significación desde un punto de vista
una habilidad por otras partes desde un
punto de vista josé aria a y al gobierno
de goni y el proceso del agua de 200
gentes con la mostra izquierda
la conformación en términos de
posicionamiento ideológico de la
convención 4 centre que laboral de este
borrador que se entregó esta
constitución que siempre voy está
conformada en términos ideológicos que
podríamos que podría decir por un
presente está ahí podemos analizar dando
de observatorio nueva constitución
etcétera no sinóptica que efectivamente
las partidas adicionales lo que es han
visto claramente reflejado un tanto de
derechas como de izquierdas por una
cuestión descripción o representatividad
los partidos políticos que es importante
que resuelvan sobre todos los partidos
que representan corrientes de
representantes están ubicados en el
centro a la derecha liberal expresa
tienen que resolver la tromba porque
están dejando sin representatividad una
elección al electorado muy importante
entonces estos puntos para mí son clave
xabi sino en re consenso y unanimidad
esta competición fue elaborada con
criterios de consenso no se logró el
consenso pensemos que durante el proceso
de elaboración de listados participaron
la ciudadanía a votar proyectos de ley
que fueron votados y debatido muchas
veces y
logró el consenso necesario para que
después no para que fuera incluida en
esta nueva configuración importante esa
aclaración que hace el occidente del
consenso y la unanimidad importante en
decirlo creo que nos queda claro en ese
orden de ideas
lucia entonces que corte tiene esta
nueva con su proyecto de nueva
constitución porque tiene que ser
todavía aprobado por la sociedad chilena
que corta entonces va a tener o qué
corte tiene
es una constitución de corte social y
evidentemente
reemplaza el modelo de un estado
subsidiarias de expansión predomina
durante estos últimos 30 años de la
democracia chilena con un estado
garantista que no sólo reconoce los
derechos sino que pone en ejercicio toda
su institucionalidad para que dichos
derechos sean satisfechos sean un vídeo
y no quede a libertad o las capacidades
individuales y una suerte de que
afectaba a quien como nación
antes eran efectivamente satisfacción en
la responsabilidad del ejército en la
guía estatal para avanzar y en recta
hacer en acción esta materia de esta
tecnología en patricio su opinión este
corte que nos explica lucía de cómo
puede ser este proyecto de esta
constitución genera entonces
prácticamente a un antes y un después en
la historia del país es un chile
completamente diferente al que hemos
visto en las últimas décadas lo que
establece esta nueva este proyecto de
nueva constitución cuál es su opinión
estoy de acuerdo que es un chile que no
refleja en la historia republicana del
país es un proyecto estatista e
indigenista
cuando sólo el 12% de la población tiene
ascendencia indígena la mayoría del país
es mestizo por lo tanto hay incluso un
sistema legal diferenciado va a haber
autonomías territoriales van a haber 11
naciones en los cuales efectivamente no
sé cómo se van a mantener no hay
limitaciones claras e incluso en materia
territorial estamos viviendo en la zona
mapuche del sur la macro zona sur una
ausencia de estado de derecho hoy día
entonces me imagino cuando se cree en
esta autonomía e indígena que quienes
van a manejar esa autonomía indígena
particularmente en la macro zona sur van
a ser los grupos más ultra más violentos
que incluso no olvidemos que la propia
ministra interior actual la ministra y
que así es viajó a temucuicui en la zona
una de las zonas más complejas de la
araucanía y tuvo que salir a arrancar
por los disparos es decir el gobierno
actual del presidente boris no ha
logrado controlar ni imponer el orden ni
el estado de derecho en esa zona me
imagino que dividido en 11 naciones y
con un sistema legal diferenciado en la
cual los indígenas adquieren más
atribuciones que los propios chilenos
creo que no necesariamente se va a
lograr el consenso ya mí me gustaría ver
qué pasa al 4 de septiembre si
efectivamente se aprueba la constitución
evidentemente va a ser un chile
totalmente distinto pero yo creo que
también hay otra salida lo que sí tengo
claro santiago es que va a haber una
nueva constitución daniela prueba hogar
y el rechazo porque creo que eso quedó
claro en el principio de entrada
patricio usted habla de esta autonomía
que pueden recibir estas comunidades
indígenas habla de 11 naciones con unos
grados de autonomía solamente el 12 por
ciento de la población chilena es
descendiente de los pueblos autóctonos
tradicionales sobre todo allí en la
región de la araucanía no pasa de pronto
por esa estabilización
s esa necesidad de garantizar algunos
derechos pasa tal vez por la por
reconocimiento de la pluralidad del
estado chileno tal vez esa necesidad de
darle ese ese título de pluralidad a un
país como chile no será el inicio de la
de la estabilización en ese en ese tipo
de zonas en absoluto yo creo en el
reconocimiento constitucional de los
pueblos chile un país multicultural pero
no necesariamente incluso se puede
discutir si escaños reservados en el
futuro congreso porque el senado
desaparece pero lo que no estoy de
acuerdo es que se establezca sistemas
legales diferenciados para los pueblos
indígenas que son ni ningún país excepto
en bolivia y ecuador que se declaró en
estados plurinacionales pero que tienen
una mayoría indígena de ser acá mi
impresión es que como que se intentó
utilizar las demandas de los pueblos
originarios en un sentido más bien
ideológico para producir nuestra
formación estructural además es una
constitución tremendamente estatista que
permite a las autonomías e incluso
desarrollar
empresas públicas
le otorga posibilidades al congreso
incluso de solicitar y llevar adelante
gastos digamos de gastos públicos a
nivel general por lo tanto estamos
hablando de una
ausencia de capacidad de manejar
macroeconómicamente el país de manera
ordenada como así orden al logro que ha
tenido chile durante estos últimos años
es un laboratorio político creo que no
va a resolver para nada el tema de la
macro zona azul no te olvides en
santiago de que los los líderes de la
cam que han sido llamados por el
presidente boris y por la ministra del
interior y que asistes a un diálogo han
dicho que no reconocen el proyecto de la
convención si no les resuelve sus
demandas yo no digo que representen a
todo el pueblo mapuche personas
organizaciones extremistas minoritarias
pero que tienen el control de
determinadas zonas en la macro zona sur
quiero presentarle a los dos a patricio
ya lucía y comienzo por lucia y también
en santiago en la capital chilena hablar
de algunos de los puntos que yo
mencionaba en la introducción del
programa sobre lo que propone esta
constitución para estelle decía cuál es
lo más destacado estos puntos
mencionamos algunos no
variedad de género que es partido del
punto base que para poder conformar esta
convención pues ya se contaba con esa
paridad de género el derecho a la
interrupción del embarazo el acceso a la
vivienda y al agua educación gratis y
llama mucho la atención la eliminación
del senado
quiero hacer estos matices a lo que dijo
patricio antes sólo establece una
segunda cámara y es una segunda cámara
de corte regional importante existe el
carácter de ratificación que el penado
ejerce a la hora de las veces que estas
profundas nada más que efectivamente y
por esto yo creo que es importante
reconocer como ha sido la historia de
chile y la concentración de poder que ha
habido a nivel de la región arma que ha
debilitado que voces se escucharan
escucharán durante décadas por tanto el
carácter de una segunda cámara regional
que representa de manera proporcional a
dichas regiones que es algo que esté
penado actual no ha y que la forma de
repartición que se tendría con la nueva
constitución si hace
creo que lo que está dando voz y
equilibrando más el poder falta al
contrario de lo que nos hemos
acostumbrado lo que se ha acostumbrado
esta función por tanto si hay una
representación de las regiones hay un un
penal que representamos mejor si tanto
fue el cierto qué la ley de las
comunidades autistas
de los pueblos originarios se pondere
por la legalidad y personalidades y de
ahí
íbamos a hablar sobre cómo funciona creo
que necesitamos claridad y no
estimaciones a partir de la creación
en reducción del miedo o un pánico por
una sociedad que hace tiempo que desde
las regiones así que estando en regiones
seguramente reconoce tiene reclamando
por tanto hay reconocimiento hacíamos
postura con la lógica centralista y
poder seguir tomar decisiones de la
presión por relaciones lógicas
paritarias y dice un poder lo social de
derecho estación no vale si son las
normas que protegen el medio ambiente y
que lo conocieran como un elemento
esencial para el desarrollo de una
ciudadanía plena
está estudiando a recibir citas que
destacan se cifraría un carácter
patricio sus puntos importantes
destacados de esta constituyente de esta
constitución propuesta de constitución
perdón
es una constitución ceja yo no comparto
con lucia que dice que se establece un
equilibrio el consejo regional digamos
que reemplaza a la cámara es yo no sé
qué rol va a cumplir efectivamente
porque no va a tener una cámara no va a
ser una cámara espejo como es el senado
sino que básicamente va a ser una cámara
que va a tener muy poco control y se va
a producir una concentración de poder en
la cámara de diputado no olvidemos que
además ahí se establece escaños
reservados también para los pueblos
indígenas por lo tanto también se va a
meter la mano al voto electoral por un
por una minoría que es muy importante
que yo lo reconozco
que hay que reconocerlo
constitucionalmente pero de ahí a darle
prioridad es establecer legislaciones
aparte me parece que es una algo
totalmente desmedido y fuera de contexto
lo único que yo valoro
en la conformación paritaria en términos
de hombres mujeres en la en
la convención constituyente yo creo que
es un avance importante para chile
también en los reconocimientos que se
hacen a las minorías sexuales que yo
creo que el chile en eso va a falta
bastante de avanzar y
en el plano del aborto me sorprende que
eso sea un tema y un principio
constitucional
honestamente yo creo que ese es un
debate que tener que tener la sociedad
chilena a través de una ley pero no a
través de un principio constitucional y
por último agregó como como se establece
una serie garantía de derecho a la salud
a la educación etcétera y bueno cómo se
va a establecer el presupuesto para
efectivamente que eso no se transforme
en ilusión no olvidemos que el si uno
analiza la constitución venezolana está
perfectamente en la pensión digna la
casa digna el derecho a la propiedad es
entre muchas cosas hay enuncia y fíjese
yo los llamaría los franceses a que
devengan a santiago y vean como en la el
lugar central de la alameda hay miles de
venezolanos para que es el norte del
país que están viviendo en carpa yo no
sé pregunta bueno si la constitución
venezolana les leyes prometió casa salud
gratis y educación gratis porque están
en chile viviendo en carpas y en lugares
hacinados en clase yo sinceramente creo
que eso es lo que refleja de alguna
manera hicieron introducción de ningún
pánico ni ningún miedo ni nada estoy
haciendo una evaluación objetiva porque
en la constitución yo puedo la felicidad
se acabó la pobreza pero yo tengo que
ser capaz de transformar eso en una
realidad y eso nos lo va a hacer esta
constitución bueno te voy a un poco más
allá de la mitad del programa tengo
varios temas para seguir analizando ya
ustedes lo ven aquí hay diferencia de
opiniones y un choque de opiniones entre
los dos invitados precisamente quiero
preguntar la lúcida patricio por la
polarización que hay en la sociedad
chilena frente a este tema frente a esa
votación que va a tener lugar el 4 de
septiembre para definir si esta
constitución esta propuesta es aprobada
como la carta magna del país que tan
polarizada dividida
con diferencias opiniones está la
sociedad chilena y también los sectores
políticos lucía
mira mucho no encuentro por la situación
a nivel de la ciudadanía de la
ciudadanía lo que están los anticipos
medios canales para el cargo para sus
demandas y lo que sí encuentro es una
hélice política polarizada todo es
especialmente una derecha con una
tremenda pataleta que hace varios meses
tema sabes cómo resolver que está
dejando una parte del electorado más
centrado sin representación sin discurso
a partir de una resistencia algo que la
ciudadanía viene siguiendo desde desde
hace décadas es decir a patricio lícito
porque dentro de sus declaraciones
anteriores empezó muchas caras y
diciendo no sé cómo va a funcionar no sé
cómo va a ser también me di cuenta que
esta acción acciones parciales militó en
el pasillo a que lea por favor entero el
borrador la constitución sean fiesta
estar de manera accesibles
interpretaciones de cada uno de los
capítulos entre ellos la fundación sigan
inteligente para la queremos
dos aterrizajes en un lenguaje claro y
sencillo para que cada uno de los
lineamientos y los artículos están
contenidas en la constitución sean
accesibles para ciudadanía y el tema del
aborto reconocidos institucionalmente
claro que es clave y esto lo vemos hoy
día con lo que acaba de pasar en eeuu
que si no había una consiguiente
partición de la autonomía física de la
mujer cualquier cambio político
significó entre el proceso para nosotras
por tanto es ante esta reconocían la
clasificación reciente van a ver que
hacer modificaciones en términos de
distribución del escrito puesto el tc
que está justamente corresponde a ser
regulados legalmente a partir de las
votaciones y como se conformen los
distintos congresos con futuro este
administración
la televisión su opinión
no estoy de acuerdo con lucía
definitivamente no creo que sean las
élites solamente las que están
polarizada el país está muy polarizado y
yo creo que estos dos meses que vienen
van a ser fuertemente polarizado no creo
que sea la derecha solamente la que está
viendo la alternativa de cambio hay un
sector de que se llaman los amarillos
que son sectores que están viendo que
venían de la es concertación es decir la
centroizquierda chilena esta semana la
que viene se produce una definición
importante de la democracia cristiana
que un partido que ha cumplido un rol
relevante en la política chilena y que
muchos de sus miembros más más
destacados de la concertación y del iii
del partido democristiano han dicho que
van a notar rechazo no sé si
necesariamente el partido va a definirse
en eso pero te indico surgió desde de
misma democracia cristiana que no
compartió ni de derecha en chile un
partido de centroizquierda
la propuesta de a través de una
solicitud que hizo el senado en su
momento en la convención de venecia para
llevar a cabo si es que ganaba el
rechazo si ninguna bajar los quórum de
la constitución para justamente generar
un nuevo proceso constitucional ya no
realizado por esta convención sino que
realizado por lo que se resuelva entre
los distintos actores políticos y las
mayorías sociales que se expresen en el
plebiscito del 4 septiembre patricio qué
pasa si no es aprobada esta constitución
en ese referendo del 4 de septiembre que
sigue entonces en este capítulo en la
historia política si ahí es donde yo te
mencionaba santiago la posibilidad que
está abriendo justamente sectores de
centroizquierda no de derecha como
planteada
esa es la centroizquierda en lo que es
cristiana sectores incluso socialistas
también que han planteado en la
necesidad de seguir que llegara el
rechazo seguir con el proceso
constituyente y establecer un acuerdo
político hay una pues está muy concreta
que yo no la llamaría ni siquiera
tercera vía que se está discutiendo en
estos momentos es la del senado que es
de rebajar los quórum para reformar la
actual constitución y por lo tanto ese
rebaje de los quórum permitiría llevar a
cabo todas las reformas que se estimen
necesarias para implementar acuerdos yo
creo que es relevante que hay que hacer
yo creo en los derechos sociales creo
que se tiene que mejorar sustantivamente
es una demanda que yo creo que se hizo
sentir muy fuerte dentro del estallido
social y por lo tanto hay que satisfacer
esa demanda la sociedad chilena
efectivamente no va a pesar que logró
disminuir los niveles de pobreza de
manera sustantiva después que terminó la
dictadura a porcentaje es relevante ser
0 a 10 12 por ciento yo creo que todavía
es una sociedad muy desigual y por lo
tanto hay que avanzar en ese plano en el
plano de mayor igualdad yo creo que está
proyecto este borrador lo que hace es
central puede permitir que se politice
la justicia y por lo tanto creo que no
va a contribuir para nada a generar
consenso a la sociedad chilena lucía y
qué pasa si está proyecto de
constitución no es aprobado desde su
opinión
tienen el papel muy fuerte para la
democracia teniendo en cuenta que
hacienda dado en la ciudadanía si llega
un ejemplo
capacidad de responder a crisis a través
de más democracia
sería una suerte en el sentido de que no
es verdad que aún facilitando el proceso
de modificación de la constitución y la
defensa que cambie en verdad el modelo
que es lo que la ciudadanía estrena
viene reclamando en los últimos años
porque porque es una constitución de un
corte como decíamos con un rol del
estado tu diario
y sobre todo sería un envase para la
democracia porque nos estaríamos
olvidando de toda la responsabilidad en
términos de valores cívicos democráticos
que implicó este proceso nos entiende
que recordemos se llevó a cabo un
plebiscito de entrada se hicieron a los
convencionales efectos convencionales
representan las distintas condiciones de
la ciudadanía forma que las prácticas
tradicionales estén pero efectivamente
lo que proponemos son intervenciones los
amarillos recibe sí que son las
contestaciones en partidos políticos de
centro izquierda y centro regresa con
sustituciones de realizar pintar es
fácil por querer mantener una estructura
que ya cayó no se puede querer seguir
haciendo las cosas de la misma manera y
debajo de ti que después es reforzar una
constitución se va a llevar a cabo un
proceso de reforma de la constitución de
1903 de
los cargos que se le quite electo en el
congreso que están completamente
deslegitimado que es pides mayor
representación regional efectivamente
pero misterio en el patio de la
democracia ha gustado específico a un
compromiso
compromiso cívico democrático típica de
el constitución nueva a cabalidad
central de interpretar debatir esto
tiene que estar subvencionado claramente
por el estado y tener que llegar a zona
unos espacios para que la ciudadanía
vote con conocimiento de causa y no por
ese pánico creado
de política que sigo creciendo que tiene
una pataleta de resistencia al cambio si
justamente el presidente de gabriel
bordi que no puede tomar ningún tipo de
partido en esta decisión de los
ciudadanos el único llamado que hizo fue
precisamente a leer la constitución a
debatir a discutir sobre los diferentes
puntos y a construir a partir de lo que
las personas lean por eso hay dos meses
a partir de la fecha de hoy para que los
ciudadanos se enteren punto por punto de
estos 388 artículos que componen esta
carta magna- me queda un poco más de un
minuto para hacer las conclusiones
comienzo con patricio que deja este
proceso esta presentación de esta
propuesta ya que se enfrentan los
chilenos para los próximos dos meses su
conclusión muy puntual por favor
patricio perfecto yo creo la necesidad
de un cambio de un cambio constitucional
yo creo que se perdió una gran
oportunidad con la convención de
producir una propuesta que permita hacer
sentir a todos los chilenos que
compartimos ciertos consensos sobre cómo
tiene que ser la sociedad chilena en el
futuro eso se perdió y creo que el
camino es un cambio constitucional pero
y la constitución porque el proyecto
fracasó en la convención constituyente
lucía su conclusión para el cierre
esta es la fiesta de la democracia en el
sentido de los consejos por la capacidad
de llegar a acuerdos amplio y
consensuado además de una extensión de
una competición electo democráticamente
por la ciudadanía que va a tener un
plebiscito de página
para mí este evento esto es la
reivindicación estratégico de la
democracia en la protección de la
democracia es un compromiso cívico
transversal se mover la tenemos que
cuidar no hay que darle a porcentaje y
poder con siempre que atendemos la
deslegitimación de la participación y el
compromiso
democrático común lucia patricio les
agradezco mucho su análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 en américa
latina' ustedes pueden seguir dejando
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales sigan con
nuestra programación sigan con france24
[Música]